let's go next to our caller from the
three one three area code who's calling
today from three one three hello hey
that's you Detroit hey Darrell
and I was just doing and I was just
wondering what your take would be on
using your your platforms one of the
largest outlet on the and on the
internet on the left wondering would you
would you which your take would be on
using to like get other smaller
platforms known
yeah so you're using my platform to make
other platforms no you're saying like
other other content or other smaller
ones like you know most people know
destiny but like people you know a lot
of other streamers do a lot of good work
battling against you know horrible right
wing ideas and I feel like some of them
could use more support and you listen to
route you I don't know if I don't know
if you're rubbing a banana on the phone
or something but it sounds very very odd
I am I the extent that I know of people
to promote that are doing good work I'll
talk about them you know the show mostly
is about political issues in topics so
that's what the focus is but if there
are specific people that I think are
worthy of a mention I will certainly
talk about them okay I'm gonna let you
go just because that something is up
with that connection I don't know if
there's maybe mice in your phone or
something like that